la mère de neutralité de ce soir aime
beaucoup ce qu'il fait d'ailleurs toutes
les grands-mères l'aiment bien sylvie
joly muriel robin jacqueline maillan
voici l'enfant prodige du nouveau rire
pierre palmade
excusez moi mais vous ne seriez pas fier
allemagne sarrazin
ça c'est drôle ça fait deux fois qu'on
me dit aujourd'hui c'est si la coiffure
je crois qu'il fait ça le brushing qui
ressemble énormément à vient pas là vous
auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
j'étais petit à fantômas mais tout reste
étonnant pourquoi j'ai envie de demander
parce que
je trouvais qu'ils et ce en déguisant
été réussi à vraiment comme si j'étais
petit alors au fond est ce que vous vous
et merci à vous lui est ce que vous vous
aimez au fond web en surface je veux
bien
oui oui oui oui je préfère qu'on me le
dise quoi on vous n
merci alors une autre question on dans
les questions tant pis je me lance vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique c'est une baguette
magique
bah déjà je me ferais une tronche je le
fais pour moi un courant et non on me
changerait n'en très longtemps moi je
voulais tout change et puis maintenant
je vous dis que mère je veux dire c'est
rare de soutien grâce à ce jeu là quoi
est-ce que ça vous plaît qu'on vous
reconnaisse dans la rue
j'aime bien j'aime bien pas le dimanche
quand j'ai fait la fête le samedi soir
avec dimanche je vais décent pour
acheter mon pain cuit le brushing comme
ça qu'on me demande si ces bilans
officiels
là j'ai envie de dire non à tout le
reste du temps et ça me plaît alexis au
jeudi a pas que j'ai un début d'érection
mais vous fait que je dit moi vous avez
été obligée de coucher pour réussir mais
avec muriel robin ah oui quand même
est-ce que vous pensez que vous méritez
ce qui vous arrive vous croyez que ça va
durer je suis un chanteur qui a fait un
tube quoi frotte l'humour c'est plus
c'est un coup d'oeil sur la vie qu'on a
est depuis qu'on garde tout le temps
quoi tout aussi sincèrement ne regrettez
vous pas déjà d'avoir accepté d'être
invité dans cette émission
non je voudrais le faire ce soir merci
bien fade